Kolchak four is a great controller but
unlike the Xbox one controller it does
not have a replaceable battery now so
that means anytime you're an out of
juice you have to connect it to the
system to recharge the battery or play
tethered to the system now that's not
really difficult by any stretch of the
imagination but nycos made the process
of recharging these batteries easier
than ever thanks to its modular power
station nycos charging device snaps on
at the top of your Playstation 4 and
draws power from the consoles to
forward-facing USB ports after you've
connected nycos unique micro USB dongle
recharging your controller is as simple
as resting it on your system the metal
contacts on the dongle align with the
points on the charge station and the
light but effective magnetic force
ensures that there's a secure connection
this gives you a convenient means of
both charging and storing your
controllers between uses while your
controllers charging the Nike logo and a
charging indicator will light up on the
front of the system once your batteries
are fully charged the lights will turn
off and the system will stop sending a
charge through the charge station
unfortunately since there are only two
USB ports on the PlayStation 4 you lose
the option to charge while you play when
the charge station is installed so night
guys modular charge station for
PlayStation 4 is a really convenient way
to keep your controllers charged between
gameplay sessions but what do you do
when you have to charge a controller
while you want to keep playing you can't
really do that when this is attached
because it takes up the only available
USB ports on the system so you've got to
take it off and I go to suggest that you
slide it over but frankly you're
probably going to scratch your system if
you do that too much more game set
content stay tuned new game spot calm
you